so so kitchen sink is a tool that you
can use to interact with remote data and
remote computation as if it were local
but we have actually two things for that
um the second is going to be a mix of
using bokeh and Blaze which are Open
Source Products by Continuum and
something that we're thinking about
releasing into the closed Source product
pipeline called the Anaconda data portal
but we're going to start off with
kitchen sink
so the initial motivation
um why I wanted to write kitchen sink is
because I was working I was doing some
Consulting work on client sites and I
was building HTTP or web-based data
access endpoints on remote machines
which needed to be hit by a JavaScript
web app client so people had to build
JavaScript web applications that would
talk to these remote machines but also
python users had to talk to the same
functions and get data back
um the first problem was that I got
really tired of writing out
web boilerplate code every time I wanted
to expose new functionality so has
anyone ever here ever written web
applications
okay who likes writing web applications
okay so there weren't that many hands to
begin with but it went down a little bit
I do not like writing web applications
even though that's what I spend the
majority of my time doing these days so
anything that sort of eliminates writing
like I don't want to write the web code
I just want to write the function and
have that automatically be called so
that was the first motivation
uh the second motivation was that when
you're deploying a web application in
production you have to worry about
things like timeouts and then suddenly
if the user is calling a function that
takes a long time to run maybe it's
killed by your timeout system in this
case we were using unicorn and got
killed by the timeout and diagnosing
these problems was really cumbersome and
the final motivation was that people who
are interacting with remote data sources
they would issue some computation from
python maybe the functions the variables
that they passed into the function were
incorrect or maybe there was something
wrong with our system but there'd be an
error and so they would get a message
back that there has been an error but
they wouldn't know why right so has
anyone worked on um distributed systems
before or working with stuff on
different machines okay so a lot of
people and so when there's a problem
what do you usually do
uh Andy what do you usually do
okay
um
so most people can't do that I think
because it's not necessarily easy to
connect to a grid and debug what I
usually do so this is the answer I
expected was most people will go to that
machine and look at a log file and it's
really cumbersome and you search for the
stack trace and you find the stack trace
and you debug it right but
um anyways being able to have analysts
who aren't python experts be able to do
computational remote machines and get
stack traces back is really useful so
um that was originally why I started
working on this route and then the
follow-up motivation is that um well
it's also nice to paralyze computation
right generally paralyzing compute is
very cumbersome
um because I think that most of the
solutions out there like disco and
Hadoop are centered around writing
mapreduce jobs
um I personally feel like and maybe you
guys will disagree that writing
mapreduce jobs is cumbersome because
oftentimes you just have a function and
you want to apply it to a data and map
does that but you don't want to deal
with reducing and other stuff IPython
parallel is a great solution for this
um if anyone has not used IPython
parallel you should check it out it's
very convenient but I am hesitant on
using it for batch jobs in production
production batch shops because the
execution subsequent execution is
dependent on the state of the current
running kernel and for a production
system you may not have that much
control over that like as you're
building up computations the current
state might be modified and then who
knows what's going to happen
um so I would like to have a solution
where these like big data capabilities
of disco and Hadoop are combined with
the interactive ease of IPython and so I
thought what would happen if disco and
IPython parallel had a baby
and I try to synthesize that into
kitchen sink so the initial feature set
is to yes
I'm sorry can you
no it's a good solution for that I think
for for production batch jobs I'm a bit
wary of it because each subsequent
function that you execute depends on the
Kernel state that like the kernels the
kernel is a live kernel and as you
execute subsequent functions you may be
modifying that kernel State and so if
jobs are scheduled differently or like
I'm I like to keep the state around a
function fairly
um
yes
but for interactive work I think I
python parallel is great so the initial
feature set is to make it feel like
you're working locally when you're
really working remotely and what we do
for that is passing back standard out to
the client and passing back errors to
the client this isn't good as good as
allowing remote debugging but allowing
remote debugging is tricky I think this
gets you 90 of the way there the other
thing to support large data sets is to
support server-side data and to support
fast formats like hdf5 and B calls are
very fast data formats I want to support
any data format that you want
um and then to take advantage of
server-side data you need to have some
sort of data locality based task routing
and then the other thing is that in
order to no so
in order to support letting web
applications talk to it you need to
support multiple serialization formats
right because if everything that you're
doing is in pickle then your JavaScript
client can't talk to the thing that you
built
okay so live demo
so I have um
two kitchen sync servers running on my
laptop so this is I'm going to pretend
like it's a remote data but really it's
local but I am talking to it as if it
remote so if it was running somewhere
else that would be fine
to just initialize the the the client
state to point to that web address
and so this is sort of the hello world
I'm just going to add two numbers and
call it via kitchen sync if I do that I
get three so here CS is just a shortcut
that I wrote for a call single it calls
a single function returns a result most
of the functions in kitchen sync are or
organized around executing many
functions because when you're doing
parallel typically that's what you're
doing
um here's a map function right it's it's
similar to the map that you would expect
it doubles everything and Returns the
result but all the computations being
done on a kitchen sink worker somewhere
um the the workflow that I typically use
in my usual computation is I use bulk
call for a bulk haul that sort of cues
up the job so every time you you execute
BC nothing actually happens besides the
client records I want to execute this
function when you call execute the
function is sent to the cluster and
computed when you call BR for bulk
results you pull the results back so if
I add one and two and I execute that a
bunch of times I get back a list of
threes
so that nothing is really interesting
about that it's just boring functions
being evaluated I think the the interest
more interesting stuff is dealing with
passing back standard out so I'm going
to execute this function and you can see
that it's printing back the intermediate
results right this sort of is a dummy
function that simulates what a lot of
people write in long learning test where
it's you're doing a long computation and
you say okay I've finished this step I
finish this step I finish this step and
you have these steps in a log file this
streams it back to you so that you can
see it interactively you can turn it off
that functionality but it's convenient
to have on by default
um and then this is going to show you
that if we so I was talking about error
handling right so I'm going to call the
add function on a string and a number
that should produce an error
and so you can see that I actually I get
the stack Trace back from the code that
was executing on the server
um but as I mentioned we're trying to do
some parallel computation
um and so here I wrote a zombie function
that we know
um
sleeps for one second and I'm also
printing out the the machine that it's
running or the configuration of the
machine that it's running on so I'm just
going to execute this in the IPython
kernel right and it's going to take two
seconds right because I have two calls
to a function that sleeps for one second
okay I can paralyze this
and it should run for one second right
so these tasks are indeed being executed
in a parallel manner
um so common issues that you often have
to deal with with paralyzing computation
is that serialization and
deserialization become a headache as
your data sets become large if you're
using something who's used
multi-processing to speed up
computations
okay so the first thing that people run
into when they're using multi-processing
is that you have all these pickling
problems so that's usually solvable it's
annoying but it's solvable the second
issue that you run into is that
serializing the data to pass it to your
your functions that becomes the overhead
and so we want to avoid lots of
serialization and deserialization and
also profiling things that are happening
on many different places this is tricky
um so I have a halfway solution no one I
don't think anyone has like a great
solution for that but I have this is the
best that I could do
um so one is just allowing people to
store data in hd5 and B calls and things
like that which are transparent because
then you can just read the data off of
disk and that prevents you from having
sent to send that data out and reading
data off of things like hd5 is generally
quite fast the second thing is that in
order to prevent you from copying to
copy data we want to move the compute to
where the data is right that's why we
take the function we send it to a remote
machine execute it and get the result
back and the final part is we have some
basic stuff around distributed profiling
um to accomplish this we have remote
data objects there are basically these
pointers that point to objects that live
on a server somewhere it's basically a
URL that represents a path on another
machine and you can access you can from
that object you can either pull out a
python object that is if the underlying
data in that file represented a pickled
or some other serialized python object
or if it's a raw file then you can call
local path and that will return to you a
local path to that data so if the data
is on another machine it'll copy the
data and give you a local path if it's
on that machine it'll just give you the
local path where that data is and then
you can also get the raw byte stream of
that underlying data
uh so so I have I have a so here if I
call C dot host I get the list of hosts
that I have you'll see that those URLs
are are displayed twice that's because
the first is the name and the second is
the URL in the default case you name the
name the same as the URL so that's why
it's repeated but you can name machines
different things
um
and then I'm going to sort of populate
some dummy data so I'm creating two
pandas data frames
um I'm calling this reduced tree
operation which is probably not nicely
named but just the point is
it takes everything that matches star
and it reduces it so that the number of
hosts that it lives on is zero right
because when you're dealing with a a
data storage mechanism where data can be
replicated it's no longer as simple as
just deleting it's I mean you can delete
but you can also like reduce it so it
lives on one host or Two Hosts or three
hosts
um and then what I'm doing is I'm saving
the different pieces of data on
different machines so I'm saving dummy
one on the one running on 633 and the
other one running on six two three four
and I can do a query for the data that I
have in my cluster which is just those
two things that I registered and I can
query it to get some information the so
the first thing that I get back here
those are the active hosts that I have
running so if a host goes down then it
won't show up on this thing and then the
other is just metadata about where each
piece of data lives and some information
about it right the format that is being
stored in the size of it the fact that
it's ready for computation that it's
fully copied Etc
so this function is calc sum and I have
this little time this context manager
that I ripped off from Dave Beasley and
it basically times the thing that's
within that's happening inside it
now part of the problem part of the
annoyance that I have with these remote
data pointers which and we can change
this later but basically you're passing
in this object which is not really a
data frame but it represents a data
frame living somewhere so when you
actually pass it in you have to pull the
data frame out of it you have to
dereference the original data frame out
so that's what this operation is and
then I'm going to print some information
about where it's running and what the
data URL so that we can verify that it
is indeed being locally routed and then
and that's the function well the last
step is to actually compute the sum
foreign
so these are the results right there the
sum of the two different columns and
then I'm evaluating six three two three
uh dummy one on the for that one and
dummy two on six two three four which is
consistent with where I stored it
um
I can also turn off data routing and if
I execute this enough times yeah so if I
turn off data router you can see that
now it's being executed on the machine
that the data is not and the two
machines are copying data from each
other
um the final thing that I want to show
you is that we have some basic
infrastructure around profiling and so
if I call Bulk results with a profile
keyword I can retrieve some profile
information which
it basically dumps a lot of numbers and
some of them are not that important but
basically
um so every time you have the time this
decorator so I had a Time subject right
around extracting DF and
um some and so
the run times for those decorators
across all your functions are summed and
aggregated into these these two numbers
so that you can see how long each step
runs in aggregate across your entire
cluster
I also have some information about how
long the job took in Aggregate and then
I have some diagnostic information so
like the start spread is the time delay
between when your first task started and
your last task started in this case it's
very small because the cluster is
completely empty and the ending spread
is the time delay between when your
first task ended in your last task ended
and there's some other things for
overhead
so uh the summary is that um currently
kitchen sink I believe is ready for
people to use I've been using it
personally on personal projects and on
some other things that I've done for
we are looking for contributors and
looking for users and when I say we I
mean I am looking for contributors and
users
um because it's basically ready it's a
useful tool I think so um and to show
you something that this is a a thing
let's see if it will load with the
network
I may have to restart some SSH tunnels
okay so this is a bokeh thing so
everyone's hear your host heard of bokeh
no
okay well bokeh is a plotting library
that we develop a Continuum it allows
for Nifty things like this this is a 90
million Road data set of taxi cab taxi
cabs in New York City
um and so what we're doing here is that
we are taking the pick up the pickup
data there's there's information about
who um every trip has a pickup latitude
and longitude and a drop off latitude
and longitude and we take that
information and we tile that into a 2d
grid and then we send that grid over
right that way you can take 90 million
rows of floats and you can send back
this like 330 by 550 grid of pixels
which massively reduces the data volume
and then you can sort of change the
shading so that it's nice to look at and
then we have histograms of trip distance
and trip time
so if I filter by
totally am to 4 AM what's happening
right now is that um the the back end
that's actually doing the computation
across the 90 million rows and doing
this aggregation is I have a kitchen
sink sitting on a machine in Austin
Texas doing this computation and then
sending me back the data
and then I can do stuff so what I did
was I filtered to 12 a.m and 4 am so
from 12am 4 am on the bottom of these
complexion plots which compare sort of
compare the densities the like the the
hit the percentiles of the filter data
versus the unfiltered data right so the
red regions are where between 12 a.m and
4 AM there are more occurrences of this
thing than during the normal time period
And so you can see like this is where
people go to party because that's where
they leave between 12 and 4 and then
they get dropped off in those places
right and then you can do stuff like
well I want to see the people that are
traveling farther so I can do that
so I selected longer trip distances and
you can see that more so I mean makes
sense right if people are partying here
and they're traveling farther then
they're getting dropped off in those
outer regions
uh does anyone have questions about that
yes
uh to do parallel processing I mean you
just take a funk like I would use
multi-processing.pool and then pull that
map and then I would send stuff to the
pool dot map and get the results back
um okay so now I want to talk about the
second thing that I mentioned which is
um I continue we're building this thing
called the data portal and it is
um it's technology around Blaze and
bokeh that allows you to interact with
remote data sets and do visualizations
on remote data sets
so uh who here has heard about Blaze
okay great
um you guys should all go to the place
talks that are happening at this
conference but essentially part of Blaze
is a blaze web server so I can spin up a
blaze web server and I can load it with
data sets that live on my machine and
also live on SQL databases and things I
have access to and I can expose them to
the world via HTTP so what I've done is
I've I have a date I have this data data
portal running and I've spun up a blaze
server and loaded it with this data and
registered that Blaze server with this
with this my data portal and so then
anyone at my company can come and browse
my list of data sets so I happen to know
that there's this Iris data set that I
like to use and I can search for it
and here's the iris data set and I get a
little preview and I also get some code
that I can use to access the data set
right so this is nice because sometimes
like let's say you do an experiment on
your computer you do you do some some
statistical analysis and you produce
some resulting some some extra result
data and you want your friend to look at
it you could either try to copy it over
a share drive or something but if it's
large that becomes cumbersome instead
what you can do is you can spin up a
blaze server register with your data
portal send this link to your colleague
and your colleague can access the data
that's running on your machine via your
Blaze web server and that's what I'm
going to do right now
so if I do
C dot Keys C is a client that's pointing
at that at my data portal if I do keys I
list all the data sets that I have I can
also do stuff like search
right and that'll return
um I have two data sets named Iris one
is just the regular Iris data set and
the other one is a filter theme that I
created
um and I can actually do bokeh plots on
that
so I just did this bokeh plot
that's the same one that was there
let's do another one
all right there we go
there you go
I'm going to remove this one
oh
all right
and then I can so I have these I have
these plots that I just created that's
pointing to data running in this Blaze
web server
um I can go ahead and make a dashboard
of it
oh this may not
yeah
I'm not sure okay
well seems to be okay
yeah
I may have to reload this
okay so I made this dashboard right and
um
can anyone give me a title
what
Fubar all right
all right so I made this dashboard
and then I've got this link so I can I
can pass this to anyone and they can get
access to this data portal sometimes
because of various things it takes a
little bit of time for the data slow and
that's why there's this delay here but
um then it will show up there and then
because the blaze server is just sort of
serving data
um I could actually there we go because
the blaze server is just serving data I
have another data set
this data is just updating every second
oh never mind
um but I can do this
so I'm gonna I have this table that
points to that remote data that's
updating
um I have to
create a bokeh object out of that
so I'm setting the polling interval to
be one that's because I know the data
set up so eating every one second so I
want it to update live
all right
yep so my plot showed up here
and so we have it
and you can see if everything is working
I zoom in it should update
yeah there we go
right so you can make streaming
dashboards and stuff using this tool
um and this is I mean this is really
quite a nice approach for working with
remote data because you can also do
stuff I mean I haven't showed very much
compute but Blaze supports a lot of
different compute things
um like if I go to the iris data set
so I just did a group Buy on the data
set that's living on a different machine
right and I'm getting the result back in
my machine in in my IPython session and
I can also do stuff like so let's say
frequently you're working with data so
you're maybe your colleague produces
some results and you look at it and
you're like okay here are the
interesting bits I've done some
filtering this is interesting bits so
let's do that right now
if I take this data set
um if I say that the interesting bits
are where the sepal length is greater
than five right
and then I want to publish this view so
that my friend can look at it
this data set there this is the filtered
one so I can send this to make this
bigger so you can see I can send this to
my colleague and say this is the part
that I thought was interesting and they
can use this code snippet to access the
filter data set that I just wrote and
then do subsequent analysis
um
no it does not copy that data set so
what it's doing is it's it's storing
um a URI points to the original data set
and is storing a Json expression graph
or a Json expression that represents the
computation that's being done on the
data set so no data is copied at
Continuum we hate data copying it's
terrible never do it
um and I think that's all I have if
there are questions I'm happy to take
them
we can talk about
um so if you're interested in this kind
of stuff this is a product that's like
new in development Blaze and bokeh open
source you can go ahead and use that and
do a lot do a lot of this stuff with it
but for a nice package that makes all
this easier
um you should look for the Anaconda data
portal when it comes out and if you're
interested in this kind of stuff you
should drop by the Continuum Booth so
that we can chat about it and uh
you can give us all your money
foreign